do you ever wonder what's really going
on in the actors minds as they film
intense scenes in vecna's mind layer or
play metallica on guitar while a horde
of killer bats approach yeah stick
around we got you
number one get ready for a whole new
meaning of death metal joseph quinn goes
through so much when playing the
infamous eddie but for an afternoon in
season 4 he gets to have quite a bit of
fun as a rock star prior to reading the
script joseph received a text from the
duffer brothers asking if he could play
guitar they kind of texted me during the
hiatus being like me play guitar i said
yes
question mark nothing he had no idea
what they had in store until much later
his reaction after reading the script
and i was just are you kidding was much
different after seeing the sequence play
out it feels earned and it feels fun and
it feels like the perfect crescendo of
this crazy sequence number two get that
kleenex ready this is a super emotional
scene for joseph quinn and for everyone
to watch quinn thinks it's a delicate
way of giving eddie some well-deserved
justice the pill that people are kind of
finding hard to swallow is the fact
people don't know that he dies a hero of
course though would we rather have our
guy eddie alive and well it's very
touching but it's still not right number
three we're jumping in right along with
you steve joe kiri for the first time
gets to show off all of the swim
training he did for the show like i was
paying for all this stuff and then we i
showed up and they're like oh no yeah we
cut that we couldn't get a pool in this
scene joe gets to plunge into a 40-foot
tank built entirely for this moment
getting to do that sort of stuff is like
true
movie magic number four sadie sink
barely made it out of this one her
performance is nothing short of
incredible
but what was it like from her
perspective
um a lot of time spent in the harness i
guess she really got to have the full
experience on this set because most of
the pieces were created by the art
department like this is the most
elaborate form of harness harnessing
that i've ever done
we also can't forget how creepy vecna
was his look is almost
fully practical which kind of
made it easier for me so i'm not like
staring at a man in a green suit number
five stancey anyone we haven't gotten to
see steve and nancy together in quite a
while so it was really exciting to see
their dynamic after all the characters
growth they've undergone not only that
but joe curie was also pumped to work
with natalia dyer again
it's fun to like work together again
actually because we haven't really
worked together in a long time though
they couldn't give us any information
regarding the future of their
relationship natalia did make it clear
that the show wants to portray two
people who truly care about each other
number six we take a visit to the
country club for this one
the scene where jonathan and argyle are
shooting golf balls into an abandoned
junkyard was one of charlie heaton's
favorite scenes to shoot in season four
he and eduardo actually had to take
golfing lessons beforehand the costume
like gave us these very yuppy golfy
golfing outfits to go turn up to this
country club in they were surprised by
how difficult just hitting a golf ball
could really be so yeah we had a lot of
practice trying to hit these balls which
were ridiculously hard eduardo was also
constantly making charlie laugh and
throwing out brilliant one-liners that
weren't in the script because of their
natural chemistry they ended up creating
some hilarious moments when charlie runs
and jumps through the window of the van
that wasn't actually in the script me
and eduardo were building each other up
so much it was like as always tension so
i just decided to run and jump through
the window number seven is this stranger
things or scooby-doo okay there's a
scooby-doo show oh yeah this scene
though it looks super cool and high-end
was actually filmed inside a warehouse
in true stranger things fashion
everything you see was built completely
by the art department gaton joe and maya
loved filming there i have a great great
memories about shooting this so this is
like a really fun and not so different
from his character steve joe kiri gets
to save a few lives in between takes
remember when you saved my life maya
hawk almost took an unfortunate tumble
off the edge of the set there was like
gaps in the thing yeah the laser was
supposed to be
nearly what off of it and joe in true
steve harrington fashion immediately
grabbed her and pulled her back up
number eight a hospital visit might be
necessary after this one this intense
scene was shot over the course of two
days about 14 hours of filming
that moment where charlie heaton slams
of vaws into tom's face needed some
extensive rehearsal
had to rehearse that so many times
safely yeah to get the choreography
michael park who plays tom was a great
sport about it though one time you
really got it i know really he said if
you hit him harder it's gonna hurt less
michael was willing to take as many hits
as he needed for the sake of the scene
at one point his entire ear was red from
being slammed so hard
due to the number of breaks they had to
take to set up for different angles they
had to sort of psych themselves up to be
in that intense heightened state that
the scene requires that also feels
really nice to come home from a day's
work and feel like you've put your body
through like the ring number nine we've
all got one david harbor isn't shy about
the way he feels working with the kids
of stranger things or feel like an angry
uncle
i guess like just a grumpy annoyed
neighbor though he may not feel like a
parent on set he did find his protective
side coming out because of that he says
that he was much harder on them than
others might have been on a serious tip
i mean i am very protective of those
kids number 10. who knew playing a board
game could be so nerve-wracking it'd be
impossible for finn wolfhard and caleb
mclaughlin to forget shooting this scene
mostly because it was the very first one
they ever did both of them were insanely
nervous the day of caleb even got sick
because of it we were all i think just
really like just scared because we had
no idea like you know we didn't have any
rehearsal or anything luckily though
nerves definitely became a lot calmer so
common fact that the guys couldn't stop
laughing it took us a while to get that
scene done but it was so much fun number
eleven cue up a never-ending story
yeah that was also just such a weird
scene it was although we're always down
to hear sadie sings incredible vocal
skills she thought the scene was a bit
odd because of all the heartache that
happened earlier in the episode max's
brother just died and then i saw that in
the script i was like what's going on
now we're just like singing and dancing
regardless she was happy to have a
lighthearted moment to balance out all
the heavy emotions number 12 we're still
not over it this is a bittersweet scene
for the cast a great day on set for finn
wolfhard is getting to do scenes with
the entire cast usually in those big
group scenes we're all just really happy
because we all get to just like do a
scene together and hang out but in this
case happiness was definitely not the
prime emotion it was pretty emotional
that day that was one of the final
scenes that were shot for season three
so in a way we're actually getting to
watch authentic goodbyes among the cast
in a way you're actually saying bye yeah
and you can and it was like felt natural
to hug everyone yeah there are so many
incredible stories and emotions hidden
behind the stranger things moments
sometimes you forget how hard the actors
have to work to give them to us what's
your all-time favorite scene